okay I'm ready okay are you yeah okay citizens of
the reject Nation apparently we're both ready to
watch the monster house it's animated we don't
know nothing about it I have never heard this
know what this it's just really recommended and
it's spooky spooky time spooky season I love
it so don't forget to leave a like and leave a
comment and also ring the bell ring the bell that
was like a spooky Opera everybody loved it don't
I know it five stars listen gr can you plug some
shirts before I talk about I would love to plug
some shirts hey ladies and gentlemen I want to
say thank you to everyone who watches our videos
and who has also been supporting the channel by
getting yourself some real rejects apparel at www.
reation shop.com we got shirt it's like this one
space babies of the Galaxy just launches Ahsoka
lightsaber scissors snip snip if you get it you
get it also got our aoda shirt we got this one
a Pedro pass SC from Last of Us carrying baby
grou little combination Child Protection Services
what we call that tea we also got who influences
the influencers watching insire and we got a whole
bunch of other te's as well that are being flashed
up on screen right now and it is an amazing way
to support the channel and also look good while
you're doing it I love everything I heard and I'm
really upset they haven't given me the groger one
every time I'm here I ask for Merch do you guys
see me in the millions of videos that I made so
far have I had any merch on no I haven't whose
fault is that look right here look right here
Bingo me Bingo baby plug the patreon super
sexy rejects don't forget that you can watch
the full reaction and and sync up with your
sync up with your own copy on patreon and you
can watch it with me and Gregory Monster House
sync up the whole thing but also don't forget
that GRE and John do exclusive highlights
and and Reaction watch the locks over there
okay are you ready to watch Monster Haw watch
monster house I'm ready to do it okay let's do
it [Music]
Amin oh this is going to be a fun spooky
time fun spooky child Wonder oh my God
I'm ex extra excited now that that logo not
know amlin was involved with this hey hey hey
baby cool title I love that o intriguing
opening thought summertime uh bye- bye
Leaf oh whoa cool camera moves there's like
only in animation can you do a great tracking
shot track shot of a Lea so great waa I hope
the next 90 minutes we're just following this
Leaf this is Terror before we
F me this [Laughter] morning
I love how the color palette does feel Halloweeny
yeah oh my God yeah I was like I
hope it ends soon but also she's
adorable get up Leaf get
up I think I feel so much danger about
a leaf that must be the monster house it
looks so spooky I've never seen this type
of animation before like the way that she
looks looks like almost like a mixture
of a video game and something else to
me
wa what my
Lord It's actually kind of creepy get out of
here my TR yeah what mean old
old man what a meanie old man
man whoa who the C these camera Jitters
are something else yeah this is shot very
cinematically for an animation like whoa Cool
October 30th another tricycle I'm coming what
another tricycle it's almost like a rear
window situation mom he did it again he
took another tricycle you cannot stay up
in your room all day staring at an old man
through a [Laughter] telescope I'm serious I'm
a man his voice sounds funny [__] creek lady
she's a brilliant actress and I forget her
name right now Elizabeth will be here in a
few hours if anything happens call the police
and hide your closet know see you tomorrow now
[Applause] oh my God child murder it's hard
to see with the mask on then why don't you
keep it off chowder tell him you love him
dear please he knows that son you love I
don't want to tell him love love you son he
knows I don't want to tell him I love oh my
God a cheer up it's almost Halloween in one
day in 3 hours it's candy time I wonder if
this takes place in an earlier era it seems like
the the babysitter will be here in 3 hours yeah
I don't think I'm going trick-or-treating
this year okay what I'm getting too grown
up oh my God it's time for an in your face
disgrace oh yeah where's my ball there's
something so disorienting about the camera work
he's going to take it is there a blend of map
with this see that's why I was like this and
the way how smooth it is your B just landed on
NE Cracker's lawn it doesn't exist anymore I
paid $28 for that ball that is expensive asked my
mom for a126 times never worked that hard in my
life that is so funny
oh man the fear of getting the ball from
the neighbor's yard God I've once had to
hop a backyard before why is he always
he's just right always right there and
ready oh property [Music]
damage dang he's a strong old man oh
my God what just terrorize my Lord
not a playground for children
got it from now on this is my
house you just stay away from oh
no oh you didn't die let him die do
it mofy what this child witness the
horrors of death as he looks in his
eyes oh gnarly shot the boldness on this animated
movie did he just die on top him
him yes bold move I respect it
wow maybe he was protecting maybe he
was keeping something like guarded
in here oh and he's actually not a bad
guy after all yeah he kind of reminds
me of the Home Alone guy and then you
realize the long guy is actually nice
Yeah Joe peshi was all right in
the end not that one the neighbor
dummy what is he not dead what's going on
he's not dead might have been too Bleak
if they killed an old guy within dying on top
of the little boy as who watch the soul leave
him it is called monster house though respect
though man a golden key all right attached to
that house oh oh there's some there's a
power with the house it eats things it's
some kind of monster house he shed it he
sh it cool all right so maybe the old guy
was really just trying to protect the kids
so they wouldn't get eaten by the monster
house I'm a murderer no you're not the cracking
of the glass is symbolic too for the boy it's z
z now listen up I'm not your mother I'm not your
friend don't talk to me like I'm a baby okay this
is her first time babysitting I don't even need
you [Music] here oh Elizabeth DJ why you break
that but I didn't yeah let me ask you something
who are they going to believe go to your room
she's harsh I mean this in a really complimentary
way I feel like I'm watching someone's like like
someone learn how to animate and put it together
themselves [Laughter] like this their artistic
Vision come to life in a way there's something
that feels like really intimate about the way it's
all drawn and kept together like the Tim buron
of old when you're stepping into strange person's
Dark Fantasy mind what hell yeah let's go okay all
right oh great changing down that is awesome what
how horrific yo this movie's [Music] committed
what it's coming for your soul that's awesome
like it's night marish expression it at the same
time I really thought I thought it was just going
to be like a cute little animated movie and
it's like this is way better way denser than
that [Music] yeah very funny see how you
like it star 69 yeah call them back this is
Satan is it coming from inside the house
or across the street that's a loud phone
if it's across the street street
right they need to soundproof those
walls this is the80s they
don't know how to do that
so when your neighbor's phone rings you can hear
it happy Halloween doofus the Z boyfriend
look at his face that's funny oh my God I
think that guy looks terrifying
who's this this is Bones what's
up I think she is Skull and he's
bones no no no this is different
listen uh wow you called The Neighbors he
died now I'm getting phone calls from his
house a phone call from Beyond the Grave
that sounds cool give her back oh her you
mind e yeah I think she's having trouble
breathing she might have something in her
throat all right I'll look into it okay
oh dud I can't wait you a jerk I hope
he dies by Monster House immediately you
are so funny oh my God she sucks too if
she thinks that's funny I know I hope they
die terrible death girl get a personality
why would this old man and be there for such
an entity chck where are your parents my dad's
at the pharmacy and my mom's at the movies with
her personal trainer that's so funny this movie
is very funny I love the writing of this it's
like it's kind of like comedy in this it's not
a Kids film it's oh no gosh Maybe neor cracker
really did die the guy is evil no he's just a
crotchety old dude oh and they know of him
when I was 10 years old I had a kite one day
it crashed down I followed the string across
the street right at the edge of his lawn uhhuh
did he take your kite yeah he takes whatever
lands on his lawn said I saw him talking to
his house and kissing it what besides the house
is alive so he like loved his own house he at
her stop it wow there's like so much lore here
I'm ready to unpack that me get out the hell just
happened what it escalated right then and not when
he tore the insides of the bunny out did he try to
go for it he I mean he must have tickled her a
little too hard throw it on the lawn they do a
good job at keeping this house is like domineering
presence in this whole neighborhood yeah the like
the low angle shot of like making the house just
look so [Music] huge watch it be swallowed great
reflection shot that's awesome you really
are dead aren't you there's a lot of like um
inanimate items that are feel alive here you're
a your kite and it's so neon and lit [Music]
up oh I'm itching for them to go explore the
house never crackers haunting me all right
his blood is on my hands and now he's coming
back for Revenge you're really crazy right
now have you noticed that I think you're
just freaking out because he killed a guy
today is this how they handled someone's
someone dying psychology when in the'80s
when you were like 30 yeah you're just like
somebody died move on like give it an hour
and just you know on I'll go dingdong ditch
the house and you'll see no ghost stop please
I'm serious come back come back here super
knows that a toy with him crawling on the
grass nom nom nom M feel like
the neighborhood would be kind
of gathered talking about this event
I thought the same thing about DJ's
parents and they just were like oh
yeah he likes a spy in the weird
[Applause] house all right buddy ditch dang dong
ditch
wow wa oh my
God W that's that looks awesome Don't Look
Back damn that crazy that's great so you can
hear a phone ring but no one could hear children
screaming their heads off in this neighborhood or
the growl of an entire home maybe the parents
you work for left you $40 in emergency money
maybe they left me 30 I read a receipt for
30 and you pocket 10 I want two extra bags
of peanut clusters one bag this babysitter looks
so much older like she looks like she's like late
20s yeah I mean she has to be right I mean she's
listening to skull and bones and dating a guy who
looks like he's 40 I know usually the babysitters
in these movies are like yeah I brought you some
chocolate chocolate cover blown yeah like they cut
into different shot they're they do good like long
tracking shots but then the editing back and
forth to tell the story in this room is like
there's a lot going on yeah and there's like the
way they deal with like where to like we the shots
like where to place the camera the perspectives
yeah have you two um seen bones I don't know what
to tell you your boyfriend has most likely been
eaten alive you said that with the smile on his
face love at first sight hello
what is it oh nothing let me see
I've never used the telescope
or binoculars to spy on a girl
before go don't go any further come here are
you guys mentally challenged can't you hear
that lady yeah come on now give it all your
chocolate and run away oh boy oh whoa who how
creative that's a fun little [Music] ride I got
her I got hello please tell me she saw that she
had to have seen something I doubt it does it
only reveal itself to like isolated adults and
or children I guess only reveals itself when
it can capture you the house they're trying to
eat us all right stop explaining I've had
a where you going I'm going to see what's
happening with that stupid House of yours what
is your problem I love that sh it's like just
they do like little subtle things with the
house to show it's always watching I'm going
to find bones all right hey you have fun okay
don't worry about us we'll be fine hi I'm JD
DJ it's almost like they choose to say like
if we're going to shoot this shot even if
it's 5 Seconds it better be interesting
yeah well there's there's also something
that feels semi vois about the way it's done
like there's always someone the point of view
is always outside like through the car looking
at them was cool Charles to the ladies um Jenny
Bennett there's a great taco stand near there
I hate Mexican food me too wow that's racist
other people make tacos too normally I don't
spend time with guys like you but a house to
eat me so first it was the Mexican food comment
now the like you comment yeah girl where do you
come from a puppy please don't eat the dog if
the house eats the dog I going to be so upset
oh God you just made an no no it's a doggy I
think it's time to call the police why yeah
well I guess I guess cuz it ate a dog with the
rug that shot out of its um door mouth oh there
go that's a great that's awesome that's so funny
this house is the devil it's going to be a blood
bath we have reason to believe that there is
a dangerous creature inside that house it may
have killed a man and a dog call him a backup we
don't have backup it's just Judy at the station
this is no situation it's just a couple tater
tots hopped up on too many pixie sticks is that
Kevin James haer tots yes time's up Peewee it's
Halloween and believe it or not we got things
to do take something that they have but if things
get out of hand throw it towards the house that's
lo I like how the house actually has a clever
mischievous personality it's cunning the three
time TR State over 14 Thou Art dead de Champion
his name is Reginald scholinski but they call him
skull there is a stranger things Vibes to it yeah
which stranger things was very Amin with man-made
structures becoming possessed by a human soul so
that the spe becomes merged with wooden brick rare
form of monster domis but how did he how did he
occupy the house though he seemed like he had a
real relationship with it You' got to strike at
the source of Life the heart maybe the old guy
just lived there before became a Monster House
the furnace is the heart if we want to put out
the fire we fill the dummy with a few gallons
of cold medicine feed the dummy to the house
house eats the medicine house goes to sleep we
get in there dous the fire and get out I don't
want to steal drugs from my father I don't want
to go inside a monster and I don't want to die I
say it's worth a shot yes I agree let's do it
why are they so determined to kill this thing
though I feel like there's a version where you can
easily get more people in on this but they are so
intive why is her determination there maybe
because they saved [Music] her and what else
has she got to do she's selling chocolate bars
out of a wagon man I could go for some chocolate
I haven't really eaten today I'm so hungry
me too we I never get snacks here oh well
just tell me I'll give you some snacks snacks
oh yeah that's what I was going to say I was
like you guys need to have like like uh you
know put on a disguise so the house doesn't
know your kids but it can see though kind of but
I'm like it's got eyes that's what I like about
it like the house is like a SP it'll just know
right that there's kids in the trash can but
then again maybe not but I think they establish
that like its eyes are open when the blinds are
open right so right now it's closed sleep may
not know yet hting on a vacuum [Music] smart
Okay so yeah they have to wait get out oh great
shot nice God Chow hide better behind the trash
can
W cool I think I'm going to go as trash can guy
I mean vacuum cleaner guys
for Halloween it's a great
costume I love that way it
rolls it out like a tongue
well no uh all right kids out of the trash cans
let's go drop your weapons huhuh pass them to me
come on I will shoot you I will shoot you you
guys are going to jail but officer you've got
to believe us we we are super casts yeah that's
why I live in a condo is there really a reason to
arrest like you mean no I'm like what for a vacuum
putting a vacuum cleaner prop in front of a house
sounds like the dangerous creature I'm going
to go check it [Music] out how are they going
to get out of that back seat once these cops are
eating by the house red spooky creature I'm going
fly what you doing that is a oh WAOW going to go
get backup I thought there was no
backup I'm getting Judy I'm getting
Judy but what does it do to you when you go
when it swallows you I don't know I mean does
it go into the fireplace and that's why it's like
the chimneys going off do they get immediately um
cremated uh-oh climb out the
back come on oh you're getting br
inside finally we get to see
what's up in there what if
it's just a misunderstood so that is so cool
looking guys come on let's go oh my God
you can get a splinter in here yeah I
mean oh finally if we find the heart we put out
the fire maybe we should examine our other options
we wait here and do nothing until it wakes up and
eats us find the heart put out the fire got it
so this house just only wakes up to eat then goes
back to sleep I guess so I'm not a lazy house like
damn that is the dream wake up to eat W to eat go
back to sleep gosh did you ever see a wife people
used to say he had one don't be judgmental but
he fattened her up I mean it's just straight up
spooky maybe she's the house
there right there shoot
him I think you got to go down there yeah
just jump down there and see what's up oh
oh it's like a gel it's a gel now oh my God
it is very inventive with how he uses like
all the household tools all the elements all the
things inside the house light if those are the
teeth and that's the tongue then that must be
the uula the what the little thing that hangs
in the back of your throat it's a girl house
it stimulates the gag reflex everyone has a
uula oh dude this is way too mature this is an
animated movie for adults I really do love his
commitment to its horror aesthetic but I am so
craving peanut butter right and quietly don't
touch anything stay together no no where did he go
where did he go through the floor oh I'll save you
oh it's everything it's ever devoured oh this
just got so much more horror movie than I ever
expected knock oh no it's a bunch of toys down
there yeah it kind of plays on that whole thing
of like when you lose something in the neighbor's
yard but yeah yeah and you can never get it back
yeah I think you guys should have a look at this
constant the giant T that's what he turned his
wife into uh I mean you fattened her up that's
what the key locks the key come on DJ we don't
have time for this yeah we've got to find a way
out of here I mean they gave you the key for a
reason uh yeah I mean you have a golden key you
got to use the lock also I would assume that the
heart belongs behind the heart lock y'all not
so smart for precocious kids oh my God is that
a dead late there she is he really did eat her is
she still like alive buried cement oh what they
they pour cement over her what I don't know is it
I always knew you were hiding something Mr never
cracker dude you got to stop falling
onto these bodies oh that that's not
that is not some sturdy cement that was like
what it's the away oh she's actually
quite skinny underneath all that
yeah it's really cool how they make like
the pipes feel like the inside of organs and
stuff everything in this house feels like it's
living yeah there's like an anatomy to it dude
why are you so stupid you we already learned this
earlier why are you so stupid what is he doing why
killer slinkies did he just yell killer
slinkies yikes yikes
whoa oh okay so it is
intentional I couldn't tell it
first uh [Music] whoa chatter you [__] yeah come
on and this feels like alien sci-fi with that
[Music] light yeah it also feels like a cool
video game that you would play where you're like
choose your adventure and what are you going to
[Music] who oh it's pushing you out you out cuz
y'all are kids but where are the other people
then I mean maybe it needed to be unlocked it
needed the help another great idea DJ I don't
see you coming up with any big Ideas oh yeah yeah
and also he just saved your life I'm going home to
make a pretzel sandwich how can you be hungry
you make a pretzel sandwich I'm going home I
suck jeez oh at least it's an
ambulance what this just got spooky who is
this what is it oh my God he lives he stole
an ambulance he's not a ghost he's not dead I'm
not a murderer he's still in his Hospital gun
yep don't you know what day this is is that Steve
Bushi yeah I'm just hearing it now running out of
time running out of time honey I'm home maybe his
soul did get her soul did get dispersed amongst
the house in the house it had to because he buried
her ruffled down there your windows are cracked
but he he unlocked it though they unlocked it
the house is her Mr NE cracker I know about
Constance this is what what this seriously
ominous you didn't kill her did you I love her
so much Golem oh you just wanted her to live
forever that's twist of fate right here yeah
okay oh that's mean that's sad oh that's really
sad this is not a kids movie it's the same cage
I take you away from here would you like that oh
now great silhouette shot feels like a classic
movie all right damn how long they how long
there's like no Community here at all right
now it's not much I know but just they were
the first ones oh that is excellent that is
excellent get away from my house oh watching
the history and development of all this those
criminals are attacking our house now now
they're they're just kids it's Halloween no
no no it's my house and they're hurting me poor
woman I will never let anyone hurt you oh go
you she really is like being terrorized
I know no oh there she goes in that's
the oh how tragic so I finished the
house she would have wanted that she
died but she didn't leave her soul is truly
tethered that's why she hates the kids yeah
that night that one night of every PTSD
yeah there is a tragedy to this I had to
hey why do they keep singling out just this
house cuz it looks spooky she attacks anyone
who comes near I I'm I'm coming dear
who oh this poor old guy I know that
you've been protecting us all these years
but now it's our turn to protect you let
her go yeah like you've lived there long
enough buddy I'll have no one that's not
true oh now you're taking away
her love wa she does not like it
she does not like it she can get up and
oh my God it's going to move around no
way it's a fullon monster movie now oh she
is pissed yeah other people have to believe
you now where's the rest of the neighborhood
yeah why is anyone running out being like why
is this house walking around on the street
maybe just try to communicate to it I'll be
all right and be like hey we're not we it's
okay Constance is it killing the humans I
don't that's the confusing part is I don't
know where all the rest of the people went
wow uh who threw
that hey h that's domestic violence nice sweet
you've been a bad girl haven't you you've Hur
people a man the way they've managed to make it
so expression it with the whole House's emotions
and I have to make things ow oh he's going to
blow her up I've always done what's best for
you haven't I this be the right thing to do
oh oh no oh no she's going to eat you leave
alone get your grubby branes off the old man
clever this actually came back around that's
clever that's really [Music] clever oh wow
oh take this what you have to help me please
where's the rest of the people that keeps
it is kind of distracting me that there's
no one else joining them to be like what's
going on going oh my God chimney leads to the
heart that's easy just get on top of the chimney
you can do it no [Music] problem fantastic TJ get
rid of that thing oh there you go you drop
it from the crane into the chimney right I
need you to get the House Down Under that crane
piece of cake I mean easier said than [Music]
done oh my God it is crumbling apart I
think you did it chowder now you still
got to destroy the heart it has the
capability of reassembling yay yes
look at me ah here she goes again oh
that was your opportunity to go into
the chimney flat ground she's a strong
woman yeah you got to use the crane come
on wa it's taking a new shape
look cooler now she looks like
the shape of waterf fish now you ain't
nothing you're a shack you're an out
house you teller chowder
[Music] uh-oh Whoa man this could have been so
much easier if he just went up to that [Music]
chimney I can't yes you [Music] can she did it
oh my God she made the move first [Music] yeah
sorry the music does a really good job of
making this feel like a big huge Adventure
it seems spooky but I also like have
a feeling they're all going to be okay
yeah crazy could cough me that that's
perfect prove your necessity for being in this
movie [Music] oh it's like the [Music] leaf stop
woo W that's
awesome this neighborhood cool is this sucks they
must have the best sleep cycles or or like they're
always inside they all have they all wasted and
asleep air plugs and sleeping masks yep they
just got the whole shebang down they got sound
waves going on in the background oh the ghost the
ghost man how are you still alive I'm sorry
Mr neor cracker about your house and your
wife yeah where's he going to live now are
your housewife housewife we have been trapped
for 45 years I thought it's longer we're free
thank you [Music] friend we're free she's like
would you like to buy some cookies cuz I'd
like to make some money off of [Music] you
yeah see she lives there whole neighborhood
of Clueless dumb asses oh now they come out
now they hear it trick treat we're going to
need a tricycle one tricycle coming up that's
cute there's my mom how is her mom not like what
happened to you she normally wouldn't hang out
with boys like them but I think you will now
see you of course she will she kissed him on
the lips on top of a crane that's a life
moment you never [Music] forget a I love
trick-or-treating me too they should do like a
trick-or-treating for adults I'm just going to go
anyway what oh he's back oh so
she didn't eat them anyone see my
kite wow what are okay wow she doesn't
e them she just swallows them keeps them
down there with the toy what a strange Dan
Harmon inter from Rick and morte dang man
wow I I did like this movie a lot I thought
that like all of the tracking shots the way
that it's shot cinematically where they're
using like but they used so many moves of
like it's a crane it's a crane shot there's a
dolly shot they use a lot of tracking shots oh
shut up who is it oh everyone's coming back
oh Nick Cannon he must be that black guy oh
Maggie gillin that's her voice God it was so
hard she was the babysitter oh John he right
what do you say shit's creek lady's name
I need to know it now inspect some candy
huha God bless her she's a genius all right
where's the car and that is how I slayed that
Mystical Dragon oh yeah no way video game guys
getting the girl not so fast bones yeah times
have changed the sk's not like you he gives
me the respect I deserve and makes time for
me it's been it's been a couple hours
yeah she moves quick oh the dog lives
go back to
Ping oh cute
adorable anyway what were you saying that you
thought God nobody cares so many camera moves
in this movie there's like a tracking shots
a dolly shot a crane shot and then like hand
moves and ins and outs and I I do like that the
way that they shot this movie or decided to edit
it was like every shot was like camera's going
to roll up here and it's going to go up here
and we're going to pull Focus from here and there
it was very uh I would just say creative it's not
like they stuck to one certain style like you're
like you look at Wes Anderson you know what you're
going to get there with this movie you're like
I don't know how they shot it they just shot it
with a bunch of different camera angles and moves
and it kept it interesting cuz you kind of never
knew what you were going to what you were going to
get there and I guess in animation not I guess in
animation it's obviously a lot easier to get very
cool shots without having to set up and set up all
these people and um I like that and I also like
that the music didn't give me anxiety when it was
supposed to be spooky that it made it feel more
adventurous and that uh I I like that it kind of
it had a tone of like it's going to get spooky and
scary but everyone's going to be okay and I like
that um I liked it I thought I thought it was fun
yeah it's a fun movie what did you think break it
down it's been long long days hasn't it yeah yeah
yeah it's been long but uh I I liked it a lot that
I do have my I do have my criticisms I only on
the table I say that to keep you reeled in let
him he like okay oh what a way to hook us I'm
going to hear what GRE say it's good first but
I'm going to stick around because he's teased
us with there's probably some things that he
thought could have been better or perhaps didn't
like I want to I want to hear that what are they
and then I guess I'll share M I'll share them
later share them later you share the positives
first but you reel them in by by teasing them
you got some things we'll share our criticism
after by way for listen this on Apple or Spotify
would just watch monster house which is a film
produced by Steven Spielberg and Robert zus and I
got that Vibe uh big time because there you know
zus has done you know like the Polar Express
and Beowolf and the Christmas carol one with
Jim Carrey there's like a lot of those animated
movies that that incorporated map yes that's what
it looks like the Christmas carol animation like
an Adventures of tin t yeah so I was yeah that was
bugging me like the look of the animation I was
like I've seen this maybe only a few times and
I'm like it now I know yeah it had like that
that that combined mixture of something that
you might have seen from like those Tim buron
like likeo production company mixed with that
zca style yeah um and of course with like the
the amlin classic you know perilous kid horror
touch but uh also with that sense of wonder in
its horror that I really liked the camera work
yeah I mean that was probably the main thing
we were talking about was absolutely excellent
here it constantly felt like there was a presence
with them something watching them like the camera
felt like there was there was a personality
to it that at times you you would get the
impression that there's there there is a spirit
watching them at all times uh I thought it was
excellent but but yeah just amazing tracking
shots and I would say the same thing for for
the works of like EV a Tintin and and uh polar
express the same time my criticisms are kind
of what I would feel with those movies
as well but before I go there some more
positive wow um it's called monster house and
I really loved the tragic tale love the title
yeah I really love the title we fill each other's
sentences that way we always finish them I really
love the title and it the monster house really
was that kind of classic tragic tale you know
when you think about like the universal Monsters
of like Frankenstein or creature of the Black
Lagoon there was always a tragic element to them
and that that made them more human and relatable
and you got that sense early on that maybe this
old guy is really not such a bad guy that there's
something else underneath the surface and sure
enough um I Lov the tragic tale that it it struck
like I out of anything it emotionally desire like
wanted me to connect to granted it comes late into
the film it was was successful yeah yeah right it
was that out of anything to truly connect to on
an emotional level sad it was sad I cared and um
like the Arc of what's his name Nebuchadnezzar was
the old man nebar that old man old man was call
him old man he's old guy in here um the old guy I
thought was a really touching story that had that
like gal de toro horror fantasy quality about it
that I really loved and like we were saying during
the reaction the Monster House itself just like I
thought I thought the the the way they would you
would slowly get to know it like okay is just a
haunted house no it's not or it seems like there's
a personality to it oh there's an actual Anatomy
to it like they they they let it be revealed over
time your understanding of what this house what
was going on and then when you go into the house
it is like you're stepping inside of a body you
know yeah and I thought so I thought that was
really great like it can't really see inside so
it has to like feel around right like the way
you would feel with your own body um yeah I
thought I thought that was all excellent I feel
like the way that they set her up what was her
name again Clarice Oh I thought you were just
going to say right now I was like why don't I
know Cassandra candra C Clarence listen Clarence
when CL when we saw Clarence okay and she's at
the circus and then it gives her like that PTSD
of obviously why she's hating kids I really like
that we got to the explanation of it set up the
character so much but it's like the the subtext
a little bit of it is like the letting go of of
like your past and certain things that you may
be so connected to whether it's someone who has
died and you can't I mean that's like a I know
a larger way more adult like metaphor that we're
dealing with but we did deal deal with that here
of like it he needed the help which of of others
to help him get out of it and help to to let go
of her so that he could freely live um except it
made it really hard for him you can't really let
anybody get that close because you know you're
your wife who's dead in the cement downstairs
is going to eat him um so tough struggle is real
but it's funny that she was eating all these kids
toys and eating mostly kids who came around and
knowing to shut up around adults and cops but
it was the kids who actually saved him and Let
Her Go Let Her Spirit go and you know her spirit
was kind of happy because she was dancing with
him and then disappeared and I'm like that was
through the help of the children they weren't
all bad yeah and I coun of those syllables on
my fingers I don't know why it's been it's been a
long day and I like to that it is actually commits
to its spookiness it commits to its frightening
qualities like this really I would categorize
like a kid's horror movie and you don't really
see that you know I just watched the Goosebumps
movie for Jack Black and that doesn't even strike
it does not even strike that chord it's just like
yes a kids movie where this I'm like oh this this
really feels like there's Peril um there's danger
there's there's frightening imagery you know and
and I love that they actually maintain that uh and
and it's kind of hard to find kid horror now like
you don't you don't really get like at least on a
big scale you don't really get that so I really
like that the the the the criticism that I have
is that there's something that leaves me detached
and I kind of feel this way with the with the
other movies I was listening to spec and I didn't
realize this was like a zamas film and and until
like they played the credits at the end or like
produced by one of The Producers is that leaves
me detached is there's something specifically
just in the dialogue interactions with uh with
any of the characters that kind of feels like no
real rhythm uh to the way it's either captured
or it just kind of feels like flatly done like
oh like there's Mo cap so they're just shooting
it right and it's just and there's no life to it
and the writing of the dialogue is not as clever
or witty as I think the movie is thinks it might
be so I don't really like the characters are like
reasonably likeable all of them are they're all
reasonably likable yeah uh but I don't feel much
life from them so they always when you have such
captivating visuals when when stuff is happening
like going I guess the best example I can give
is what it's kind of unfair to say this with
a with a 2023 movie um like across the like the
spiderverse movies where when it's just dialogue
I'm just I am still engaged where here when the
dialogue was happening like it just kind of feels
a little disconnected it's kind of like when we
watch monsters Inc or minions no not Monsters
Inc I'm sorry minions we watched right and we said
it was either minions or a different movie weable
movies one of the Despicable movies but we made
the comment saying that it felt like in this ADR
in the in the voice over work that it's as if they
put them in a room and they were moving around in
the same environment yeah rather than just like
here's a mic and I'm doing this character and I'm
reading it for for just the dialogue which maybe
this is kind of what they were doing I forget what
movie we we said that we said that for How to
Train Your Dragon yes but it's it's map so they
have to have been in the same room right yeah
you're I um I don't know I maybe I think it's
really I don't know then there's a flat type of
level of Direction I think the way it's delivered
like thrown away more yeah or even the way the
C like the camera just feels like it's lazily
plopped on when usually when they're just talking
yeah and so there is a lack of Rhythm to there's
like there's no editing energy to it there's and
then so it kind of loses spark to me and then and
I just I guess I'm not a big fan of just the way
a lot of the the dialogue overall is is done MH
and I don't know if there were some really funny
parts but I were some really funny part there were
some really funny parts um but I it's just kind of
like a dry en that I guess if I have to summarize
in this it's a dry energy um to to the way that's
done and so that leaves me just going can we get
back to like the the the SP the spookiness yeah
can we get back to the house like the house like
just get back to the the stuff you know where
where I was never truly engaged with any of the
and and normally in like any kind of horror movie
or horror adjacent the thing that makes it truly
gripping is is the stuff outside of the horror
you're invested in so then when the horror stuff
is happening you're just it it is the cherry on
top and here I was like just get back to the the
the fun spooky stuff because I'm not really that
interested in the charact like they should have
that stranger things effect where you really like
the personalities of these guys AG so then when
they're going into the dangers of it all you you
you really like even if you're not knowing like
their whole backstory or whatever you just really
like their personalities right and here it was
just kind of ringing a little flat just because
of the way and I think it had something to do
with the combination of the the way they directed
specifically with the camera work around them yeah
cuz the camera work got really interesting anytime
it would not be people talking right it it moved
around like a a bit more and made everything else
seem much larger than life than when they were
talking it kind of like dampened out a little
bit yeah and if all the tropes of like chowder
just being like the funny like chubby kid you
know uh you that funny sidekick chubby the girl
pops up and then the lead I forget what his name
was I knew the only name I know is Chows uh but
I do agree in in the sense that we never really
got to know the lead character as much of just
being like oh he's being left at home fine he
gets a babysitter but um yeah I don't know that
I cared too much if whether he was going to be
whether they all lived or not I guess I was more
emotionally attached to the mystery yeah and like
wanting to know the house and the lore and like I
said the old guy stuff came in very late but but
I was really into that me too you know I was into
the old guy stuff in the Clarance obviously and
that's yes definitely her name it's not and this
movie is almost two decades old so I know I'm
giving two decades 2006 apparently whoa okay so
that's why it feels because it just it does feel
outdated with the way that there the characters in
here uh you you wouldn't be able to do that today
is kind of there was some stuff going on in there
and so now it makes sense that's 2006 um but uh
yeah I guess it's it's setting up the foundation
of this film wasn't like oh you're going to care
whether they live or die we kind of always felt
like these kids will always be fine but they're
our way in to this home to figure out the heart
of the story which was the heart of Clarence and
the old guy letting her go but I do agree if they
had gotten to it a little bit sooner they were
just like a resource to get in there but um yeah
if maybe we had gotten to it a little bit sooner
maybe it would LED I don't know to us carrying a
little bit more right off the bat I'm not sure and
I do think it needed a bit of that stranger things
Vibe where you get the sense of Hawkins Community
yeah it it does become distracting when you're
like there's so much emphasis on this house in
the neighborhood but you don't get a sense of the
neighborhood at all right but when when the ending
does show you there's a neighborhood there's a
neighborhood they don't they came out at the end
I know yeah and they have like he could hear the
the door the call ringing across the street
cop could hear the house too the cops could
hear and then suddenly the the house is coming
to life and thrashing everywhere and no one's
doing jack or scared or like what's happening you
know and I think you I do think it needed that I
I I I found it distracting it's not just like a
logical plot hole thing like when when your setup
is about the house in the neighborhood we need to
see the neighborhood we do and it would have been
nice for the whole Community to see old man not
being shown as like old man is not just being old
mean man he's being that for a reason and if the
whole Community has to come together to be like he
needs to let this house go because it's Clarence
uh needs to be let go and released yeah um would
have been nice for the whole Community to see that
he's not mean he just he was trying to protect you
all wouldn't that have been such like a a spee
moment if it's like at the end of the community
like what's this house it's walking around and
then he has to yell like I was just trying to
protect you or if the kids did it for me or the
kids did it like he's just trying to protect us
and then the whole Community is like wait what is
she I don't know they explain it Clarence is in
there her name's definitely Clarence it's not um
I question it every time you said it i' just like
yeah it's not it's definely um that that could
have been fun for the I do agree with you like
they they came they came at very convenient times
of when it was happy world the neighborhood is
out and their trick-or-treating uh but during
the crazy times it was like dead town I don't
know why it was like I think there was a lot of
cre visual experimentation though that it seemed
like a lot of the stuff they were doing story-wise
to help justify a lot of the things they wanted to
experiment with what they could bring to life like
the real character of the movie is the Monster
House the real character of this movie is the
animation the real character of the movie is the
camera work and and yeah I agree I love the music
too and and I think that um I the thing is like
what I I feel I do feel strongly about the things
I I did I I criticize however I do feel strongly
about the things I really did like or love so to
me I'm like no I still Edge towards yeah this is
a great movie for especially kids to watch kids to
watch to get an attainable horror film um around
Halloween time like this is a great this is like a
this has that Halloween spooky spirit that I think
is really fun um and I think the animation is and
those moments is gorgeous and the things that I
think are really that really work work really
strong so yeah no I would definitely recommend
it U for that fact it's just yeah there's like
other things like a could have been could have
been like a perfect film of of like Wonder but
didn't quite capture that still really really
did enjoy it there was still a little bit of
more story to be done but other than that like
they did well with what they had yeah man wrap us
up T while I set us up to I'm going to wrap it up
by just saying I had a great time here with you
watching Monster House sir and um that's it you
guys know to be super sexy we got to do a patron
shout out listen we love you be cool be kind be
nice leave a comment tell us how cool we are tell
us how much you like this movie what maybe what
you didn't like to I don't know what else should
we watch stuff like you guys know what to write
in the comments like as long as you're cool
nice kind you WR whatever you want tell me I'm
pretty uh okay let's do a patron shout out get
to it all right so here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna do okay thank two people to there's
two people here I think could be understanding
we're behind on our shout out so I got to combine
a couple great we're going to do it spooky time
we're going to have a great creative time here
we're going to put Eric Horseman the man with
the real reject tattoo he has an actual real
reject tattoo cool I know I want to see it
in person when you die can you put it in your
will that you have to tear it off your F some
they have to like tear it off your flesh and send
it to me put it in a bottle with that like fluid
that keeps it alive forever that cereal then it
can grow tentacles and then this is already part
of your shout out and then Ana Oliva who we've met
in person quite a couple of times real sweetheart
and uh always had a crush on John no not not as
big of a fan so I wanted to do a shout out here
with of the thing that's going to replace all
screenwriters chat gbt so um I wanted to do one
of Eric Horseman and Ana Oliva together yeah and
then how they would spend their Halloween time so
we're going to need some things here all right
pumpkin all right hold on hold on hold on you
got to properly prompt this thing fine cuz it
doesn't know how to you got to be its director
I was ready but keep that in mind okay I have a
YouTube channel where I need to shout out two of
my patrons ano Liva and Eric Horseman write me
a shout out about them meeting on Halloween and
what goes goes down no what you mean including
pumpkins yes ghosts including pumpkins ghosts
and Reese's ghouls Reese's candy and a good
time and and a good time period some notes
about their personality wow as well Eric
loves horror Star Wars animals works at a
hotel and is very very
sarcastic you Eric is an absolute sweetheart from
Texas who has a crush on John Humphrey from real
reject that's so cute works at a bar loves her
family a Ana Eric also has a good heart all right
this is a novel is it ending yet oh good hey
everyone as the Moonlight sets the stage this
Halloween I've got a spooky tale to share with all
of you about our two phenomenal patrons Ana Oliva
and Eric hman is that oh my God this is go I'm
only uh a foggy Halloween night in a small town
pumpkins glow in every doorstep Anda our Texas
Gem has a golden heart with the lon star state
is setting up a pop-up bar for the night and know
it's not just any bar it's Halloween themed filled
with concoctions that seem too Eerie to drink
oh in the corner a jukebox is playing Halloween
Classics and if you listen closely you can hear
her huming along dreamily thinking about John
Humphrey from the real rejects enter Eric horor
ficado and a sarcastic smirk with a sarcastic
smirk and a Star Wars cloak because why decide
between [__] and SciFi when you can have both
as he approaches the bar he sarcastically comments
this doesn't look like a hotel I work at as to
which an laugh and pours him a drink and they both
Bond over their love for animals and family and
Eric sharing Hotel tales that would make even the
bravest Souls chuckle with trepidation suddenly a
group of ghost schools appears challenging them
to a racist camp Cy eating contest Anissa with
her inherent Texans Texan competitiveness and
Eric not one to back down from a challenge he
Dives right in the two show the spirits that
the two show the spirits that humans too can
hold their own in a Halloween especially if it's
sarcastically presented did you say that no did I
miss you skipped like a whole sentence I missed it
listen the night continues with laughter laughter
laughter mischief and a whole lot of candy the
one once Eerie fog now seems like a blanket of
camaraderie embracing everyone in his worm so
here Ana and Eric two amazing Souls who not
only support the channel but also know how to
have a good time May Halloween be filled with
as much fun goals and races as this magical night
wow whoa you guys wow we're being replaced that
was a lot I don't think so because I'm going to
tell you right now I could have given a shout
out and it would have been a quarter of that and
justce fun okay I tell you I tell you that right
now people were asleep halfway through my reading
of this novel okay damn so we love you all there's
your shout out and can we go home and go to sleep
now please for the love of God yeah end it for me
pleas